6 25 on your Monday morning want to make
sure you caught in one of our eight news
Now updates on how that diverging
diamond on Tropicana is driving you
crazy
in a 30-minute time frame Friday
reporter Ryan Matthey saw not one not
two but three wrong way drivers there if
you drive the way you used to or the way
maybe you think you still should despite
the signs and the arrows on the road
you'll be going the wrong way
here's how diverging diamond traffic is
supposed to move some advice from the
Nevada Department of Transportation
spokesman Justin Hopkins don't
necessarily just follow the car in front
of it because if the car in front of you
makes the wrong movement you don't want
to just uh follow them blindly really
pay attention and understand where
you're supposed to go
now some more advice if this is all too
confusing maybe skip Tropicana
altogether you should be able to get
where you want to go by using either
Russell Road to the South or Flamingo to
the north by the way that diverging
diamond setup and can be in place for
about a year and a half until the
all-new crop debuts with four lanes in
each Direction no diverging diamond but
that's not till late next year or maybe
even 2025. buckle up drive carefully
please put down that phone join the
driving you crazy conversation we are
traffic eight at eightnewsnow.com